hi my name is Justin co and I'm an
engineer on the Android wear team let's
look at how your app can let users
provide voice input to notification
actions with Android wear Before we jump
in make sure you've checked out the
previous video on the basics for
developing for Android wear including
how to optimize your notifications for
the wrist and remember to check out
developer android com where you can sign
up for the Developer Preview and browse
the documentation so imagine we've built
a messaging app that has a reply action
in new message notifications something
like this when a user presses reply on a
phone or tablet you would take them to a
screen that would let them compose and
send the reply like this if we don't
optimize this notification for the wrist
pressing the reply action on an Android
wear device would simply open the reply
screen on your phone but we can do
better with the remote input feature of
the Android wear API we can hint to
Android wear devices that our app can
accept freeform voice input in response
to the notification so here's what that
looks like let's show the notification
again and reply from our Android wear
device the user gets presented with a
voice prompt along with a custom hint in
this case reply to bugdroid they can
then speak a reply like I'll be right
there and after confirming the reply
text is sent to the app the key here is
that the app can skip the phone UI
entirely simply sending off the reply
text in the background let's look at the
code to build such a notification first
we use the standard notification compat
builder to create the notification will
emit the reply action for now since
we'll add it later next we'll build the
reply actions pending intent this intent
will be started when the user presses
the reply button on the phone note that
the intent should be for an activity
because otherwise pressing the action
won't close the notification shade
finally we'll use the remote input
builder and action builder classes to
construct an action that will be capable
of receiving voice input extra reply
text tells Android where the name of an
intent extra to add to the reply intent
when a voice response was provided
then we simply need to wrap our
notification compat builder in a
wearable notification builder that's it
to handle voice replies in your reply
activity simply check if the extra you
specified earlier has any content if it
does you know that the user responded
with their voice from their Android wear
device and you can simply send the
response and finish the activity
immediately otherwise show that activity
as you normally would and that's all
there is to it the remote input feature
of the Android wear API can help you
simplify your users lives by providing a
seamless wrist optimized user experience
for responding to notifications there
are even more ap is for customizing
notifications for Android wear devices
so be sure to check out the
documentation and sample code in the
Developer Preview on developer android
com thanks and happy coding